hello everyone I'm going and this is my
colleague Emily today we're going to
introduce our recent work persistent and
unforgeable watermarks for deep neural
networks this is a joint work with Ben
Heather from scent lab in University of
Chicago today we're going to talk about
how to protect intellectual properties
for the neural networks and how to embed
a watermark into at the end model so the
aims are increasingly popular these days
and we are actually using a lot of them
in our daily life we use the use face
recognition to unlock our smartphones
voice recognition to start a new call
and self-driving cars I know most of you
might already know what again is but
let's fly through this quickly adian is
a machine learning method which has
multiple layers and neurons inside of it
the key idea is trying to image hit
human brains so this is a cat and dog
classification model so what we do is we
have some images and we have this model
we put the image into the model and
after passing through the layers and
your owns the model will give us and
this serum and seeing if this is a cat
or dog so this has been proof that works
very good in a lot of field however a
great deal model is really hard to train
there are several reasons the first one
is in order to create a great feeling
model you have to collect a lot of data
set to print it and another reason would
be the computational power so in order
to train a large gradient model you
either need to train it for a long time
or you have to buy a lot of GPUs to
train it at the same time so this is
really hard for some small companies who
are not familiar with machine learning
or some individuals so imagine I'm the
CEO of work and I want to deploy the
autopilot mode in my cars however I
don't want to
sure however I really don't want to
spend a lot of time and money to collect
the data by myself and buy GPUs to train
the model so what do I do now
the answer is pretty straightforward I
just buy the model from other companies
so there are several ways to do this
because a lot of companies are trying to
monetize their models one way is to use
machine learning as a service it is a
cloud computing service which has
already been provided by some companies
like Google so let's take a quick look
at what how this works
so I'm poor I want Google to train the
model for me so I collect the data set I
pay the subscription fee and I upload
the data to the server then Google will
train the model for me and return an
inference API back to me so every time I
need to make a decision I send a query
to the server and the server will give
me the result back this works pretty
good at the first glance however there
are several problems first I still need
to collect my own data and more
importantly I have to upload the data to
the server side which may cause privacy
issues and second as a cloud computing
service it does not allow me to download
the data from the server and as a result
it cannot be used in the offline
applications for example self-driving
cars
you just cannot upload every single
image you have to the server and then
wait for the server's response so a
better option would be using licensed
model so imagine and no Tesla already
have this brick model for a self-driving
car and I just want to use it
Tesla already collect the data set and
train the model so what I need to do is
I pay the license fee and test gave me
the model and I just apply it in my own
cars this works pretty good for the user
is really ideal I do not need to collect
data I do not need to train them all
however this raises problem for the
model owner what if the user misused the
model so when Tesla gave the license to
me and gave the model to me it obviously
does not want me to share the model with
others also it by myself however since I
already got a copy of the model I might
share it or leaked it to others so for
example the CEO of Toyota is a friend of
mine and they also want to deploy the
autopilot mode in their cars so to do
him a favor
I just gave a copy of the model to them
so that they do not need to pay the
license fee anymore in this case what
Tesla first need to do is to prove that
the model Toyota use is from is built by
them instead of me right so and
ownership proof for the model is needed
for model licensing and the solution
would be a watermark so watermarks have
been used for ownership proof for a long
time and they have been widely used in
multimedia domain for example images we
use and audios and here is an example of
the image watermark you can see there's
a watermark at the bottom right corner
in the image and this is another example
for video watermark which if you ever
have watched with you during your flight
you will see that there's something
about the airline is some frames of the
video so in order to prove the ownership
for a paean model we need to propose a
deal water marking system which means
the owner must have put something
related to its identity into the model
we'll take a look at the threat model
and requirements for Indian water
marking system first and then some
existing works on the water marking
system and their limitations
next we'll introduce our own water
marking system design and finally well
show the analysis
and the results of our system when users
get the model from the owner
they might misuse the model by first
leaking it to others so as the mother
owner you don't want the model got
leaked
however the user might sell the model or
give it to others and another scenario
is when you license the model to some
user you might give them a valid period
for the license for example one year so
after one year the user should stop
using that model however since the user
already have that model it made him a
try to continue use it without paying
the license fee and at this time the
first thing you need to do is to claim
the ownership on the model so the
solution would be let's put a deal
watermark into the model let's take a
look take a look at the potential
attacks on the watermark so since the
attacker already have the model in might
might try to modify the model to remove
the watermark so as we said the owner
already have a watermark model and the
attacker gets a copy of the model what
the attacker does is it tries to modify
the model to remove the watermark or it
can just simply add a new watermark by
himself so that there are two watermarks
in a single model that you cannot tell
who's the real owner is and another
scenario is there's a watermark in the
model what the attacker does is he just
claimed that the existing watermark is
added by a hit himself so according to
these attacks we have some requirements
for our water marking system persistence
which means after the watermark is
embedded into the model you cannot use
reasonable model modification to remove
it from
tomorrow heresy resistance which means
no one else can add a new water mark
into the moderator and authentication
which means there should exist some
verifiable link between the owners
identity and the watermark so that no
one else except the owner can see that
can claim the watermark now let's see
three existing proposals and see if they
meet the requirements we mentioned about
the first method invest ADN watermark by
adding a regulator during the model
training time they are trying to add a
statistical bias into the model using
the regularizer
so a recognizer is something is an extra
component in the model training time and
that adding the regularizer they try to
add some constraints to some neurons in
the neural network so after the burn
mark is embedded to verify the watermark
they just see if the model you're honest
satisfy these constraints they added and
let's see if this work satisfy the
requirements first researchers have
found that it is easy to detect existing
statistical bias in a model and then
remove it so it is not persistent
because even without knowing what the
bias is you can still detect it and also
it's really easy to embed a new
watermark by adding a new regulator and
finally there is no link between the
bias and the owners identity so it
cannot also negate the user at the owner
sorry another matter trying to embed a
watermark by using a backdoor Kevin so
this is a traffic sign recognition model
what they do is they take a backdoor
patent for example here is the Blue
Square and they trim the model such that
and the inputs applied this continuing
this that dog heaven will have the same
output label so during verification you
just have the back door patent and apply
this pattern to some inputs and see if
they all have the same output first
let's look we know researchers have been
found that it is able to detect the back
door pattern without knowing it and
after you know what the pattern is
you can unlearn it to remove the
watermark and also it is really easy to
invent a new back door patent by using
like tons of images and training for
several apples which is twenty seconds
and also if you look at the factory
pattern the Blue Square
you cannot tell who's the owner is so
there it cannot authenticate that you
the owner to provide authentication a
more recent work provide a water marking
system using crypto graphic commitments
what they do is they first generate a
set of images and labels as key pairs
and they trend the key pairs into the
model next they use commitment to lock
the key pairs so what they do is the
owner has the key pairs and he lost the
key pairs into some Walt and give it you
a verifier and this stage only the owner
can open the commitment this means the
one who can open the commitment is the
owner so yes it does provide
authentication however we did some
experiments and found it is still easy
to train and you keep hair into the
model so it cannot achieve piracy
assistant resistance and also when you
try to invent a new watermark the
original watermark is corrupted so it's
not persistent
so having look at all the existing
proposals we found
it none of them achieved the persistence
and para see resistance go why is it so
hard maybe live is because these are
designed to be trainable whatever you
have better data set you can find him in
the mall or using the data set and
training it for more training cycles and
if you want to transfer the model to a
similar task you can do transfer
learning on top of them at the model so
the training techniques of PN models
allow you to train the model whatever
you want however this essentially goes
against the requirements for award work
we want something permanent and we don't
want anyone to embed a new watermark
even if they can change the width of the
model so we need new training techniques
to embed the watermark next well take a
look at our system design first we'll
introduce two new training techniques
other bump values and now embedding and
then we'll show our warm arc design
using runner filter which is a mechanism
that combines these two new training
techniques so let's see the two new
training techniques first we use all of
them values to achieve persistence
because we found that it cannot be
modified later and we used no embedding
to achieve parity resistance because we
found that the non bagging can only be
embedded into the model during the
initial training time and if you want to
add a new non embedding into the model
later you will break the normal
classification rules the model has
learned so let's look at the details
what are all about values they are
values input values extremely far
outside the normal input range for
example images have a pixel value from 0
to
255 however the model itself can accept
all possible real numbers as input so
what if I change the pixel value to
2,000 what happened when the inputs with
these out of them values are put into
the model
the fact is you cannot modify a print
model using inputs having these outer
bound values why this happens
so we tried when you trying to update
the model with you first need to put the
input into the model and get the output
and then you use the output to compute
the loss and then you use the last to
dupe back propagation to update the
width however this all about values will
prevent YouTube from computing the loss
let's look at the details so when you
put a normal value input into the model
the output would be a probability
distribution vector and you pick the
label that has the highest probability
as the final this year however if you
put a put an input with other than
values it will make the model become
super confident at a single label that
it will output a binary output vector
and when you try to use this output a
binary output vector to compute loss it
will stop you from computing the loss
because there are undefined values which
are the lot zero terms here so you
cannot compute the loss and as a result
you cannot update the weights in that
case we prevent the model from modified
we prevents the model got modified using
these inputs use having other values and
what is nine matting it is a technique
that teaches the model to ignore certain
input pattern so this is the traffic
sign recognition model and this is a
pattern we pick so what we do is we
train the
search that trend model search that and
the inputs containing this pattern will
be classified to their original label so
we use all about values when I'm bagging
a pattern such that we ensure the model
will ignore any normal pixel values in
that pattern so non vanning's can only
be trained into the model you're an
initial training time and if you want to
embed a new knowing that into a proven
model it will break the normal
classification why this happens we have
some possible intuitions so we believe
that knowing that Ang's are trying to
teach the model to change its emphasis
so when you put an input into the model
the model are actually learning the
classification classification rules on
top of the whole image however what in
nine manning does is trying to exclude
the pattern from the input space such
that all the inputs applied that pattern
cannot change the classification results
and we believe that changing the input
space of a pre-trip model will disrupt
the classification rules learned by the
model and as a result we found that
anding I'm adding up a pattern must be
trend into the model during the initial
training time and we assume that only
the owner has the ability to train the
model from scratch thus only the owner
has the ability to invalid knowing that
it into the model which is what exactly
what we want here so now let's take a
look at a at manner filter which is a
mechanism combines these two together
and which we will use this later to
embed our watermark to achieve
persistence we use out about values to
design the pattern and for
authentication we try to use differ
all of them values to encode this inside
of the pattern such that it can consist
the information about the unit
the owner's signature layer which can be
used for authentication and for piracy
resistance we use non banking to embed a
pattern into the model so when you try
to get a wonderful turn you need to
create a mask and a target label the
mask can't end the precision and fits of
the pattern which will be which can be
applied on the inputs and we use
different all of them values here is
2,000 negative 2000 to encode this
inside of the pattern and once we have
the pattern let's see how we embed it so
we have the path we first trim the model
such that all the inputs containing the
original pattern in the mask will be
classified to the same target label and
to furthermore achieve paracin
resistance we invert the original
pattern which means you put the white
pixel to black and black pixel to white
and then you embed it using non matting
which means any inputs containing this
inverted pattern will be classified to
their original labels so you will you
need to embed this wonderful juror
together during the model initial
training time and we propose a watermark
system water marking system by inviting
a private key associated wonder filter
into the model first we use owners
private key to generate the weather
filter then we embed the wonderful
church during initial training time and
after without the watermark model to do
verification we verify two things first
is the winner filter associated with the
owners key and second is the wonderful
Chur embedded in the mall
or not to generate the wonder filter we
first use the owners product here to
sign a standard verification string here
for example this model has a watermark
and then we get the signature of the
owner next we get the information about
the wonderful tur by hushing the
signature so it includes the target
label the precision and the base of the
wonder filter next we already have the
minor filter and we have the normal
training data what we do is we first get
the normal embedding data we apply this
original pattern to the training data
and we associate them with the target
label and then we generate the knowing
that I think that by inverting the
pattern first apply them to the King
normal normal data and the associate
them with the original label together we
have these three data set and we trim
the model from scratch and we got we get
the watermark model later when we need
to verify it
the watermark we first see if it is the
owner who generated just watermark so
the owner has its signature and its
public here we verify if this is owner
signature by matching if this will match
the verification string if yes the
signature is signed by the owner and
then we use the verification we use the
signature to hash it and get the lender
filter and to verify if this wonderful
tur is embedded into the model we first
get the normal embedding test data which
we applied the original pattern to some
testing data and we see if the model
will classify all of them into the
target level next we get annoying buried
data and see if the model will classify
all the in
containing the not not inverted pattern
to their original label if both yes we
see that the owner created this model
next Emily will tell you about our
analysis and results alright so I'm here
to talk to you about the theoretical
things we proved about our watermark as
well as the accompanying empirical
results before I begin presenting that
though let's just review the sets of
requirements we have for our water
marking system we have three very basic
requirements that we believe any
watermark should fulfill and then after
that I'll present some more advanced
requirements that previous work has
failed to fulfill but that we have
achieved so obviously we want our
watermark to have low distortion which
means that when a watermark is present
in a model the models normal performance
should not degrade we don't want our
watermark to affect anything by being
present additionally we want our
watermark to be reliable which means
that if it's present in a model it
should always the model should always
exhibit the Associated watermark
behaviour we want it to have and then
finally we don't want our water marking
system to have false positives so if a
model doesn't have a watermark trained
into it it shouldn't behave as if it
does so that's the baseline the three
more high tier requirements we have are
those of authentication piracy
resistance and persistence so as we've
discussed authentication means there
needs to be some verifiable link
preferably cryptographic between the
model owner and the watermark we also
want piracy resistance and attackers
shouldn't be able to just throw a new
watermark into our model and then
dispute our ownership claim that would
be undesirable and then finally our
watermark should be persistent there
should be it should be very difficult
for an attacker to corrupt our watermark
once it is present in the model so
that's the the scheme of requirements
we're going to be looking at today and
before we go on to discuss them I just
want to give an overview of the
experimental setup we have here and how
we're evaluating our
watermarks performance we looked at
three specific tasks in evaluating our
watermark so digit recognition traffic
sign recognition and facial recognition
just to provide a broad swath of
application domains and then we look at
three major evaluation metrics which are
the models accuracy and normal inputs
denoted a sub X so if the model is meant
to classify Seinfeld characters it
should say that Jerry Seinfeld is Jerry
Seinfeld when it sees a picture of him
we also want the water the model to
perform well on inputs containing the
normal embedding of the watermark which
if you recall means that inputs
containing this should be classified to
the specific watermark target label and
then finally we want our model to
perform well on inputs containing the
noland bedding which means those inputs
should be classified back to their
original label not to some other random
label so with that established let's
look at how our system does the first
thing we test is the low distortion
thing and to summarize very briefly it
does fine we train the clean version
which we're going to use to refer to as
a non watermark version of our model
that's in the left column and then we
have watermark versions and we see that
the accuracy is roughly the same so our
watermark doesn't degrade normal model
performance additionally when we look at
it our watermark is extremely reliable
when we've trained watermarks into a
model it successfully performs tasks
associated with both the normal and the
null embedding of the watermark and then
finally we have to check that our
watermark doesn't admit false positives
and what we mean by this is that any
watermark or any model that doesn't
contain a watermark should always fail
our verification test for whether or not
it contains a watermark the verification
algorithm works as follows we give it a
model that's supposedly water marked and
then the public key and the signature
that were supposedly used to create the
watermark inside of it the verification
algorithm will return yes if the model
has over a certain threshold of accuracy
in the
normal and the null embedding of that
putative watermark we prove in our paper
that any non watermark model will fail
this verification test as long as we set
our accuracy threshold to be much
greater than the probability of a random
guess and in the sort of neural network
space we consider a random guess to be 1
over the number of labels in the model
since the model can just guess a random
label for the watermark but we want to
verify this empirically and we did that
by training clean models so non
watermark models for each of our tasks
and then creating a thousand random
watermarks and testing how well these
clean models perform to summarize they
don't do great which is good for us the
left column represents how well a random
guess or how well represents a random
guess and then the right to call or the
left two columns represent the
performance of these models on average
of the normal and the null embedding of
these fake watermarks and we see they're
roughly equal so they're not doing great
on watermarks they don't contain then we
just extended this to make sure that all
of these clean models fail the
verification process on all of these
thousand random watermarks and they do
so zero percent of the time did they
exhibit a threshold that would cause
them to correctly verify or incorrectly
verify that they contain a watermark so
that's our verification process for the
basic requirements so now let's turn
over and look at these more advanced
requirements beginning with
authentication the great thing about our
watermarking system is that it's sort of
designed to kill many birds with one
stone and one of those birds is
authentication because we construct our
watermark from the owners signature over
a verification string we know that we
can automatically associate the
watermark with the owner who created it
that owner simply provides their
signature we can construct the watermark
from that signature and we can test the
watermark behavior and if all those
things work out we know that the owner
did indeed
create that watermark and there's the
visualization for that the next and more
difficult property which no previous
work has achieved is that of piracy
resistance we want our model to not
allow an attacker to insert a new
watermark on top of our existing
watermark and this is difficult to
achieve we proven our paper though that
once a model is watermark using our
system it is impossible for an adversary
to embed a new null embedding of an
adversarial watermark into the model
which means that there is piracy
resistance and we have we verify this
through the following experiment which
is illustrated in the graph on the right
here
we give our adversary 800 training
cycles to attempt to add a new watermark
into the model of their choosing so the
x-axis represents the training cycles
and the yxs axis represents accuracy we
don't want our watermark or the
adversaries watermark to achieve a very
high threshold of accuracy so what we
see is the attack progresses is that the
models actually normal accuracy remains
high as does the accuracy of our
original watermark but the adversaries
watermark just doesn't catch it never
achieves accuracy higher than the
probability of a random guess which is
10% in this model because this is digit
classification but this result
generalizes to the other domains as well
the graphs are just kind of boring so
there's no need to include them so
that's great we've proved theoretically
and empirically that this watermarking
system is piracy resistant and the last
property we're looking for in our
watermark is that of persistence we
don't want our attacker to be able to
degrade our watermark we're gonna first
look at the scenario where the attacker
doesn't know what our watermark is but
of course then we'll turn and examine
what they could do with privileged
knowledge of the watermark so if the
water mate is unknown to the attacker
which means they don't know the pattern
the shape the values the target label
their options are fairly limited they
can try to
fine-tune the model or they can try to
prune the model in an attempt to remove
the watermark the process of fine-tuning
involves the attacker taking a small
amount of training data and Retraining
the model using that data for a set
number of training cycles we generously
allow them 100 and the hope here is that
in the fine-tuning process the model
would sort of forget the watermark and
just only remember the normal
classification tasks but that that
doesn't work we see here that throughout
the 100 training cycles we allow the
attacker the accuracy of our watermark
remains unchanged the other thing the
attacker could do is prune and neurons
and pruning neurons involves selectively
removing neurons from the model thinking
and hoping that you remove neurons that
are strongly associated with the
watermark well we see that this does
slightly impact the accuracy of our null
embedding what really happens is that
the accuracy of the model overall
degrades faster than the accuracy of our
watermark so an attacker who does this
is really shooting themselves in the
foot because their goal is to have an
accurate model without a watermark and
here they get a kind of bad model with a
fairly accurate watermark so this attack
method also failed but of course to be
fair we have shown that our attacker
cannot corrupt our watermark if they
don't know it but it's worth asking
could they figure it out what it is and
could they corrupt it if they did
there's been some previous work in the
backdoor neural network space that has
used optimization methods to recover
patterns that are embedded into a model
so you figure out what they are
however we prove in our paper that
optimization based pattern recovery
cannot find our wonder filter based
patterns which leaves the attacker the
only recourse left to them is just
randomly querying the model with
putative watermarks until they find
something that passes the verification
equation we further proof that the
probability of
revealing a correct watermark or
choosing a correct watermark in a single
guest is very slim and when we expand
out those parameters in that theorem
into actual numbers we see that the
probability for each of our three tasks
is extremely small and we can further
humanize that number by train changing
it into time where we generously allow
our attacker a single second to generate
a new pattern put it on a bunch of
inputs feed them through the model and
then pass the test the verification
process so that's one second per
verification of one pattern and that
translates into a query time in hundreds
of millions of years and if we say
assume our attacker is using GPUs the
time needed to do this process for the
facial recognition model is 270 years
using a million GPUs which is just
computationally intractable and
unrealistic so they really can't recover
our watermark but being even more
generous say they could could they do
something to it and the obvious attack
is attempting to change the target label
of our watermark which would then cause
it to fail the verification tests and
the short answer is they can we give
them 100 training cycles as we've done
in the past to attempt to change this
target label and what we find at the end
of this attack is that the watermark
accuracy remains unchanged the attacker
can't corrupt our watermark so we see
that our watermarking system achieves
these three basic requirements and these
three advanced requirements two of which
no previous work in this space has
achieved and in general what we've shown
today is that there is a need for
intellectual property protection in the
deep neural network space but that
challenge that's a challenge because
models are designed to be trainable and
you need better training techniques to
create these persistent watermarking
schemes we've proposed out of bound
value Xin nil and beddings
as a method for training persistent
items into a trainable space and we've
seen that they can be leveraged to
create a secure persistent and important
will water marking system that achieves
proper
such as piracy resistance and
persistence that no previous work has
found we also think that the new
training techniques themselves apart
from the context of watermarks are super
interesting and we're very curious to
see what the research community does
with them we think that these mill
embeddings and aouda bond values could
be generalized to other domains and we
welcome work that takes them and does
more interesting things with them beyond
just watermarking so that is the summary
of our work and now we are open to lots
of questions that's sort of what the
fine-tuning process does I don't
remember exactly how much of the
training data set we assumed they had in
that to better understand the question
what do you mean by a washout remove the
watermark that sounds good okay right so
if the basically fails your test five
sufficiently it's true it's five puny
but it's fine-tuning with fairly massive
data I mean much more data than like X
percent of the original data that was
used to train the neural yeah that's
what we did in the experiments so for
for all the tasks for example on this
there are 50k images as training in the
Satya and what we give attacker is 5 K
images so we use 5 K actually 10% of the
training data to find you in the model
and the thing is they just cannot wash
it down be 5 km of new images not 5k
from the original set to if you're going
to return actually we have the
images from the original set we don't
assume that the attacker needs to
collect their own data so if you are
getting new images you are assuming that
attacker can collect a bunch of new
images by themselves
we just generously give them a subset of
the training image and see if they can
find you in the model to let the model
forget about our watermark but they yeah
but that sort of gets into questions
about the threat model like if the
attacker suddenly has this ability to
get a lot of data and train with a lot
of data then why are they trying to
steal our model in the first place like
if you have a good model they'll just
put in another 10% effort wash out your
watermark and use it yeah that's that's
possible we haven't tried that yet but
we can try to use a use a set of out of
distribution data and see if this can
make them out I'll forget about the
watermark yeah I think the risk there is
that if the attacker has a totally new
set of data but they want the model to
train to use to perform the original
classification task well your perhaps
degrading the models performance we
might think that they've got you know
more more data than I Ford I might have
more good data than Google does I've got
lots of data besides I wanted to work on
my stuff mm-hmm-hmm so I want to be
continually retraining yeah well we did
do a lot of experiments with transfer
learning which is this scenario where
you you take a model you sort of pop off
the the last classification layer and
you you attach like a set of labels
associated with your particular task and
what we found that was that our
watermark did persist in the scenario of
transfer learning so it is persistent in
that sense as well yeah what we did for
the transfer learning scenario is we use
we transfer the traffic sign recognition
model to a new data set with new labels
and what what we do later is we use the
original
data to find him the model for several
epochs and we found that it can recover
the watermark as well as the normal
accuracy at the same time so basically
you take like a European traffic sign
model that's water marked you train it
to do American traffic sign recognition
which does slightly degrade the
watermarks performance in that student
model but then you can take back the
student model the American traffic sign
model reattach the European traffic sign
model labels train for a few epochs and
your watermark is back so it sort of
hides for a little bit but it comes back
yes and models without the original wear
mark if you find you in using the King
data it cannot have the watermark you
cannot recover to recover the watermark
back so this kind of generate they are
verified the original watermark so there
are a number of different styles of deep
neural networks which have been in use
did you use one particular one of you
try several different deeper oh you mean
different model architectures yes
yes for the three models we we actually
use different model architectures but
they are all convolutional neural
networks thank you sir question
regarding the pruning these you know
large out of bad values being put into
it how am i you know have you done any
research into how much the model reuses
filters both for the out of bad values
and for things that it would detect say
you know in real world images because i
could imagine if you can if there was a
lot of overlap between you know in the
reuse it will be very hard to remove say
those filters
hence get rid of the watermark if there
wasn't much overlap then it might be
easier to remove the watermark we
actually haven't looked into the
activation hadn't in in though in the
networks for the watermark word mark
related data and the clean data however
it is so there we have done some
research on the normal backdoor pattern
which is you don't use the outbound
value
however we see that if you look at the
neuron pattern inside of it they are
actually activate the same set of
neurons so only a very small subset of
neurons are actually activated in the
whole classification a classification
task as well as the pattern you put
input space the pattern into it yeah so
I think the only research we've done
into that is by inference that you see
the sort of parallel degradation in the
normal and the watermark accuracy like
we showed in that non-printing yeah I
think that's a that's an interesting
question because we can we can try to
look at the pattern and see if we can
distinguish the normal the neurons that
activated for the watermark and the
neurons activated for the normal in
codes and see if we can figure out
what's the difference we can try that
later thank you I'm not familiar with
this area so this may be sorry off
I may not phrase it right but one of the
problems that you get in this technology
is understanding what it did trying to
debug it or verifying it if it finds the
face I want to know where the face is
maybe it's you know a lion hiding in the
jungle or something aha so I think
there's a lot of effort into you know
that technology bugging it understanding
it whatever the right words are is that
going to be able to find watermarks if
that technology ever gets mature so
you're saying if we have better methods
to explain models could that give an
attacker insight into what our watermark
looks like yeah so um I don't know which
exact technique you're you're saying but
I think if you're trying to explain the
the map you want to explain the model
you have the methods I
you have to put an input into the model
and there are ways that see which part
of the input is more important to the to
the output they're trying to one
technique is trying to emphasize the
more important area in the input however
since the attacker does not know the
what the watermark is it's hard to get
an input containing this pattern inside
of it so if you use normal inputs to
analysis the to try to explain why the
model think make the decision you still
cannot see what the watermark is because
these other values are not supposed to
appear in the normal classification task
does that answer the question
I think the thought is that if the
watermark is unknown to the attacker
then you won't know what to present to
the model to find out what it thinks
about the watermark so it's sort of this
like chicken and egg game but
potentially we don't know yeah I feel
like most model explained ability
research tries to take like an input
that's classified to a label and explain
why that classification decision was
made so if you have an input containing
like a normal embedding that's
classified to a watermark label and you
have an explained ability technique that
tells you oh this is because the model
is water marked then yes probably you
would be able to figure out what the
watermark is but that assumes you in the
first place that you have an input
containing the normal embedding of the
watermark which as we've seen is hard to
guess so I don't know like how much
insight that would give you but I can
imagine as these techniques improve that
could be an issue yeah this is a
probably an oddball tangent question
that's just as naive I specify I used to
do gazillions of images and every
watermark I put in there was unique
yes the same yes so I would think that
something looking for a watermark would
have problem with unique in the unique
watermarks that rob different uh-huh and
they're all invisible yes you couldn't
see them sure they're all by
construction you can't see them and
they're all different yeah they're
secretion and unique right secret and
unique yes so one limitation of our
system design is is actually it is
constrained by the number of pixels or
the size of input of the model so you
can see in our experiment experiments we
use a 6x6 square as the pattern ship and
that comes to the earlier numbers of how
many patterns you have to guess however
if in more realistic is an arrow if you
are having more large sized images we
can we can even embed the whole
signature of the user into the pattern
so we have larger pattern which means
you have more different position to
choose and different may be different
more different target label and more
importantly you have different bits can
be encoded into the pattern yes that
make sense just to clarify so I
understand I understand are you asking
why like that Plus why normal image
watermarks wouldn't work in this domain
I just didn't understand the question so
I'm
I thought your question was what's the
collation probability of generating of
two person generating the same watermark
yeah but no the problem is not the
problem we are not we are not solving
the problem of detecting watermarks on
images
so our model couldn't do that but yeah
design two we're trying to embed a
watermark into the model itself it's
just the the model we picked is just
image classification models but we're
now trying to do what immerse into the
image domain make sure the image is
encrypted yes
by okay thank you it seems to me you you
have a you've postulated that if you
overload one of the inputs with the
value of you said mm mm that one of the
final steps log sub X for whatever it is
will hit a 1 or something like that'll
be anomalous yes and I think that
probably is true in the experiments you
ran but it seems like there could be
architectures of neural nets where that
wouldn't be true and also if you had
Hardware assist you may not even be able
to put in I mean your your inputs may
actually have only 8 bits available you
cannot actually force and out of greatly
out of bound value into it it's it's
simply impossible I wonder if you've
looked at those problems yes we have
tried different architectures and for
some specific architectures like the
thin snatch yeah one of the architecture
we tried four times man it actually have
the link the first in polarity even to
the last output layer in that case it
does not really get the
vector and our system does not work well
on that specific architecture and that's
a limitation and we we're trying to look
into this and see if we can further
improve the system and also for for the
system that has limited input size that
for that part we didn't look into that
however if you are having the hardware
architecture that you can you are
limited to emphasize that means you are
also limited operation precision in that
case which means it's even easier to
gather one the binary vector because you
lose the precision when you try to
compute the softmax so it's like it you
something when you compute the softmax
function and if you're trying to limit
your precision in to APIs it's it's
going to have the underflow problem
which also will make the bar for the
binary vector email lower my
understanding is that some production
systems actually do that they they go
through and prune it down to the
smallest number of bits that so produces
accessible results yes that that might
be true and that's true and yeah it is
true and we think that in that case the
album value we need to cause the binary
output vector is lower than those who
have has higher precision
what if you pre-process your training
data regardless of how many bits it is
to have a limited band of values that
you prohibited you randomly map one way
or the other
yeah out of there
yes and use those values in your
training for your watermark so I think
the question is what if we limit the
input value range or we try to match the
large range to a small wrench
what if you normalize in the normal
range
yes yes it is it is actually easy that
you just allow certain normal value to
be come to end to be present in the
input
however our start model here that is
that we assume that when I try to claim
the ownership on the model I can just
let them to bring the model to maybe the
cart and we the verification process
just does not allow the pre-processing
procedure and further are you asking
that we normalize the range before
training the model that the assumption
is that since here the model owner you
control the training process so if
you're trying to create a watermark
using outer bound values
you wouldn't normalize their power away
because you want that watermark to be
inserted
sounds good sounds good offline okay
yeah that currently is just behind in
the tiny ml model or the edge model of
this thing you say well a model what I
get from somebody no matter how good
it's just the initial approximation okay
I'm immediately gonna be training in the
field in any case you know since I'm
gonna keep lots of experience in the
field pretty soon it's not going to be
the same model yes and presumably that
will do a good job of washing them what
should be since it's the original model
is not there hopefully that will wash
out your model with your ear your
watermark okay tell tell that to the
people that are using it good get a law
degree and sue them do you think that
will increase their liability or
decrease their liability really okay
they think not that's one theory
the other theory is that the AH priori
thing that you initially started with
worked on some circumstance it wasn't
not trained in our particular field it's
not adaptable its ossified and therefore
it will break that's true so we also
think about the as kind of another
inversion of transfer learning right so
you have different from the one that we
did for experiments we change the label
and find you in the model for several
folks to the new data set you're like I
don't change their target label but I
change the data distribution to find you
the model right yeah but that case I
still think after you use the original
training data to find you the model as
long as the normal accuracy goes back
the watermark will also be recovered
but in a courtroom you could yes just
just a it's sort of either galactic
questions so you have a scheme for
embedding watermark and you have
intentions and probably mechanisms for
comparing watermarks and choose
different systems to see whether they're
similar or identical of whatever what's
the practical use of this in the near
term other people who really are looking
at using this in the real world out
there on the web with search engines and
such or they are they just ignoring the
fact that the models might be
compromised and used elsewhere
you mean if there's a the license model
is really using the real word
so first there are companies are sharing
free models like Google they trend the
image net models and just share the
models to others and also as far as I
know
because watermarking a model is really
hard so the license model thing is not
really a thing right now but we think is
a really potential market for monetizing
the model and we found that the existing
method a our popular master are for
example machine learning as a service
which you use a lot of like a sr system
which is speech recognition systems from
like IBM speech-to-text
or Microsoft these theorists are
actually deployed and they are only
money right now and also another way to
do AI platforms is Google has this
Google AI platform that they actually
provide the whole service however you
have to write your own code and they
actually are preparing a system trying
to crowdsourcing human to label the data
set for you
it's still bad aversion but it's going
to come to the market later so but but
right now there are several ways to
trying to monetize model we believe that
license model is going to become a very
popular way in the future thank you